It's 6,371 kilometres to the centre
of the Earth.
Follow us down.
We're going all the way
to the heart of the planet.
Our world is made of layers,
a bit like an onion,
and as far as we know, life only
exists in the first layer -
the crust. In the crust, you'll find
the burrows of animals
such as moles and badgers.
The deepest are made by
Nile crocodiles
and can reach depths of 12 metres.
The crust is also home to ancient
underground cities
like Elengubu in Turkey,
an elaborate labyrinth capable of
housing 20,000 people,
complete with schools and chapels.
It is thought to have been built
around 370 years BC.
The world's deepest mines can go
down to around four kilometres.
South African gold miners have found
worms two kilometres down,
but all life stops before
three kilometres.
Then there's the deepest hole
ever drilled -
the Kola Superdeep Borehole
in Russia.
Some call it the gateway to hell,
with locals claiming to hear
the screams of tortured souls.
At around 30 to 50 kilometres depth,
we reach the next layer -
the mantle.
It's made of hot rock, which appears
solid to us
but actually flows very slowly,
just a few centimetres a year.
These delicate shifts below can give
rise to earthquakes above.
In the 1960s, a group of scientists
attempted to drill
into the Earth's mantle.
Although unsuccessful, new efforts
are afoot with a plan to drill
deep below the Indian Ocean.
As we descend, the increasing
pressure
means that atoms become warped,
and even the most familiar materials
behave bizarrely.
Crystals change from green to blue
to brown,
and rock becomes as malleable
as plastic.
2,900 kilometres down, we reach
the bottom of the mantle.
See those two giant blobs?
They're the size of continents.
Scientists aren't sure how they were
formed or what they're made of.
They cradle the next layer -
the outer core.
In Jules Verne's classic novel,
Journey to the Center of the Earth,
Professor Otto Lidenbrock encounters
an entire underground world,
replete with prehistoric creatures
and a subterranean ocean.
While the dinosaurs might
have been a bit of a stretch,
there is an ocean of sorts,
but this one consists of flowing
red-hot iron and nickel,
a sunless sea with its own currents
and jet streams.
This motion creates a magnetic field
that protects the Earth
from dangerous solar rays.
The final layer is known
as the inner core.
It's 6,000 degrees in here.
The pressure is so intense
that the metals here
have crystallised, forming
a solid sphere
at the very centre of our planet.
In reality, our little vehicle
would have been crushed
and melted long ago.
And as for our driver, I think
she better head back to the surface.
It's a long way to go.
Good luck!